autres titres de l'actualité la montée
des eaux en méditerranée un phénomène
rare qui avait été anticipé par les
services météo d'europe du sud
à nice la mer s'est élevé de plusieurs
dizaines de centimètres en croatie
plusieurs villes ont été inondées venise
a également été touchée sophie mais elle
virginie travers explications des
bateaux coulés dans le port de
villefranche les restaurants alentour
endommagé les carreaux cassés les
troubles ont volé dans les vitres et
l'oua voilà et l'eau de la mer est
rentré presqu'au bout du risque pour une
situation tout aussi agité à ajaccio où
des vagues de 5 mètres ont dévasté une
boîte de nuit qui donnait sur la plage
c'est grave quand même jamais eu de
tempérer aussi forte depuis très
longtemps aussi longue et aussi plus
tard dans le nord de la croatie
la mer était un maître 17 au dessus de
son niveau normal du jamais vu depuis
presque 80 ans d'où vient une telle
intensité
le phénomène est connu en cette saison
dans le nord du bassin méditerranéen
il combine de hautes pressions
atmosphériques et des vents puissants
venus du sud
conséquences les plus abondantes qui
généralement russell vers la mer sont
freinés on a donc une conjonction à la
fois en termes de précipitations mais
effectivement la mer va réagir avec des
houles et où des vagues qui peuvent
déferler et être assez importante à
venise le même phénomène est amplifié
par la situation particulière de la
ville c'est l'époque de la cua alta les
grandes marées qui submerge certains
quartiers mais cette année comme tous
les vingt ans les ont particulièrement
déborder un mètre soixante au dessus du
niveau habituel
débarrassé de ses pigeons la place
saint-marc est presque méconnaissable
promenade incongrue et malgré tout bonne
humeur au programme
pour les touristes on en vient tôt